c'est les organisations non
gouvernementales partent en campagne
contre l'utilisation comme soldats des
jeunes de moins de 18 ans une conférence
se tient en ce moment à berlin pour
faire pression sur les gouvernements et
sur l'opinion
la grande-bretagne et la france ont
annoncé qu'elle ne souhaitait pas
modifier l'âge de recrutement dans
l'armée fixées respectivement à 16 et 17
ans géraldine d'allemands moréas ils
sont 300 milles à travers le monde
ils ont 7 10 ou 12 ans il se bat en
tchétchénie au liberia ou encore en
albanie des enfants soldats enrôlés
endoctrinés armée qui jouent à la guerre
mais pour de vrai c'est pour lutter
contre l'inacceptable qu'une centaine
d'organisations non gouvernementales
sont réunis pendant trois jours à berlin
l'objectif établir un protocole
additionnel à la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
qui interdisent toute présence de
mineurs au sein d'une armée
un protocole qui se heurtent d'ores et
déjà au refus de nombreux états et pas
toujours ceux que l'on croit
car c'est bien à la position de certains
gouvernements occidentaux que cette
conférence s'attaque à des pays comme
l'angleterre ou la suède qui organise
des stages militaire à partir de 15
voire 13 ans la france quant à elle a
indiqué qu'il était hors de question
qu'elle remette en cause le recrutement
militaire dès l'âge de 17 ans entre
garder ses lois et montrer l'exemple
il faut parfois choisir